CONVENING OUR ASSEMBLY COMMITTEE
ON BUDGET FOR THE HIGHLY
ANTICIPATEDHEARING WORLD THE
PUBLIC COMMENT WAS DIRECTED
TOWARDS. LAST WEEK SO WE ARE
HEARING FIVE BILLS THAT CAN BE
PICKED UP ON THE FLOOR ON THE
ASSEMBLY FOR LATER TODAY- WE
HAVE TO PUBLIC FINANCES WAS OUR
LEGISLATIVE ANALYST. PRESENT
THERE WILL BE NO VOTES IN
COMMITTEE HOWEVER WE ARE
ACCEPTING PUBLIC COMMENT AT THE
END OF THE HEARING- BUT ARE
THERE IN THE HEARING ROOM IN THE
ROOM FORTY TWO A TO HEAR THE
CAPITAL OR- VIA THE PHONE LINE
THE PHONE LINE OUR NUMBER IS
EIGHT SEVEN SEVEN. SIX NINE TWO
EIGHT NINE FIVE SEVEN. IN THE
PUBLIC ACCESS CODE IS ONE THREE
ONE FIVE FOUR TWO OR TWO THAT
NUMBER SHOULD BE FLASHING BEFORE
ME IF YOU'RE WATCHING ONLINE.
ALSO IF YOU HAVE ANY PROBLEMS
PLEASE FEEL FREE TO CALL CUT THE
ASSEMBLY. BUDGET COMMITTEE
OFFICE AT. NINE ONE SIX THREE
ONE NINE TWO OH NINE NINE-
FORGET WE ARE FIVE REALLY ACTION
ITEM BILLS OVERTAKING UP TODAY
AND WE'RE GOING TO BE PRESENTING
ON THE ASSEMBLY FLOOR- WE REALLY
PREFER WE APPRECIATE THE
ADMINISTRATION WORKING WITH US
TO. GO THROUGH OUR TRADITIONAL
BUDGET PROCESS RATHER THAN USING
THE DISASTER RESPONSE EMERGENCY
OPERATIONS ACCOUNT PROCESS. OR
THE JOINT LEGISLATIVE BUDGET
COMMITTEE PROCESS THIS WE
BELIEVE THIS PROCESSES MUCH
BETTER AND PREVENTS- PRESENTS
THE PUBLIC OPPORTUNITY TO GIVE.
INPUT BUT ALSO ALLOWS THE
LEGISLATURE OPPORTUNITY TO
REALLY. REVIEW THE BILLS AS WELL
AS TO HEAR THESE ITEMS. SO ON.
THE PARTICULAR- FOR THOSE OF YOU
WHO HAVEN'T SEEN THE AGENDA WE
HAVE A BE EIGHTY FOUR-
SUBLIMINAL PAID SICK LEAVE
ECONOMIC- A B. EIGHTY SEVEN
ECONOMIC RELIEF WHICH IS THE-
COVERT NINETEEN PANDEMIC-
PRIMARILY TO TAX CONFORMITY BILL
WE HAVE AN AMENDMENT TO THE
BUDGET ACTIVITY BE ONE FORTY
SEVEN. AS WELL AS AB ONE THIRTY
NINE WE HAVE A HUMAN SERVICES-
ISSUE THAT NEEDS- DERBY ADDRESS
. AND ALSO A ONE FOR TWO IS AN-
HE'LL- WE THAT. LET ME SEE IF
THE COMMITTEE MEMBERS OF ANY
COMMENTS SINGLE COMMON WE'RE
GOING TO GO. CALM THIS ERICA LEE
WITH FIRE. GOOD MORNING THANK
YOU- MISTER CHAIR- GOOD MORNING
CHURCH HANK VICE CHAIR FONG AND
MEMBERS OF THE COMMITTEE
ACTUALLY WITH THE DEPARTMENT OF
FINANCE PRESENTS EARLY ACTION
BUDGET AGREEMENT BETWEEN THE
ADMINISTRATION. AND THE
LEGISLATURE AT THE CHURCH'S
MENTIONED THERE ARE FIVE- BILLS
WHY NOT. BUDGET BILL JUNIOR AND
FOR A COMPANY TRAILER BILLS THAT
ARE INCLUDED IN TODAY'S
PRESENTATION. THE BILL INCLUDE
BINDING R. LANGER TO ADDRESS
IMMEDIATE. CONCERNS IMPACTING
CALIFORNIANS WAIT
FOR JULY ONE EFFECTIVE DATE. AND
I WILL BEGIN WITH SB ONE
FOURTEEN THE COPING.
SUPPLEMENTAL PAID SICK LEAVE
TRAILER BILL. THE FIRST EARLY
ACTION TRAILER BILL DEALS. ISSUE
OF PAID SICK LEAVE IT'S INCLUDED
IN EARLY ACTION ITS INCLUSION AT
EARLY ACT RECOGNIZES THAT
CALIFORNIA MUST TAKE ACTION NOW
TO SLOW THE SPREAD OF PUBLIC
NINETEEN IN THE WORKPLACE WHICH
AFFECTS WORKERS AND THEIR
FAMILIES CO WORKERS AND
CUSTOMERS. FILAMENT TRANSMISSION
WORKERS WILL BE ABLE TO TAKE
PAID TIME OFF TO AVOID GETTING
OTHER SICK WHILE NOT LOSING
INCOME. THIS BILL REQUIRES
EMPLOYERS TO PROVIDE UP TO
EIGHTY HOURS UNTIL THE NINETEEN
SUPPLEMENTAL PAID SICK LEAVE. TO
ALL EMPLOYEES THROUGH SEPTEMBER
THIRTIETH THIS YEAR. EXEMPLARS
OF TWENTY FIVE OR FEWER
EMPLOYEES AS WELL AS INDEPENDENT
CONTRACTORS. IMPORTANT TO NOTE
THIS PROGRAM WILL COVER OVER 75%
OF ALL EMPLOYEES IN THE STATE.
COLLEGE OF- PLAYS ME USE FORTY
HOURS OF SUPPLEMENTAL PICK SIX
UNDER CERTAIN CONDITIONS
INCLUDING IF THEY OR A FAMILY
MEMBER ARE UNDER QUARANTINE OR
ISOLATION ORDER. BY A PUBLIC
HEALTH OFFICIALS. ADVISED BY A
HEALTH CARE PROVIDER TO ISOLATE
OR QUARANTINE DUE TO COPE IN
NINETEEN CONCERNS. ARE
EXPERIENCING KOBE NINETY
SYMPTOMS AND SEEKING A MEDICAL
DIAGNOSIS ATTENDING AN
APPOINTMENT FOR COMING NINETEEN
VACCINE OR BOOSTER SHOT.
EXPERIENCING SYMPTOMS RELATED TO
A COUPLE NINETEEN VACCINE OR
CARING FOR A CHILD WHO SCHOOL OR
DAYCARE HAS CLOSED DUE. TO THE
NEXT LEVEL. AN EMPLOYEE MAY. UP
TO IN A FORTY OUR AND BECOME
EMPLOYEE OR THEIR MEMBER TESTS
POSITIVE FOR COPING NINE. THE
BILL PROVIDES A PAID SICK LEAVE
IN HOME SUPPORTIVE. AND PERSONAL
CARE SERVICES PROVIDERS AND ONLY
THE PROVISIONS OF THE BILL ARE
RETROACTIVE TO SICK LEAVE TAKEN
BEGINNING JANUARY FIRST OF
TWENTY TWENTY TWO. MR SURE WOULD
YOU LIKE ME TO CONTINUE WITH-
THE OTHER FELT. THIS WOULD JUST
GO THROUGH ALL THE BILLS AND
THEN. WILL L. A. RESPONDED THEN
WE CAN GO TO QUESTIONS. OKAY THE
SECOND BELL IS A TRAILER BILL SB
ONE THIRTEEN- ECONOMIC RELIEF OR
REVENUE. THIS TRAILER BILL
INCLUDES MANY SUPPORTS FOR
CALIFORNIA BUSINESSES INCLUDING
FOR THE MILLIONS OF SMALL
BUSINESSES THAT WERE NEGATIVELY
IMPACTED BY A PICKUP IN NINETEEN
DOMINIQUE DISCIPLINE CLUED A
REPEAL OF THE LIMITS AND TAX
CREDIT AND THAT OPERATING LOSS
OR AND- WELL USAGE FOR THE
TWENTY TWENTY TO TAX YEAR WHICH
WERE PUT IN PLACE. AS PART
TWENTY TWENTY BUDGET ACT- IN
RESPONSE TO SIGNIFICANT EXPECTED
STRUCTURAL DEFICIT AS WELL
SIGNIFICANT DROP THE REVENUE
REVENUE PICTURE HAS IMPROVED
DRAMATICALLY AS WE DISCUSSED AT
LAST WEEK'S BUDGET HEARING- IN
THIS PROVISION RESTORES THESE
CREDITS WHEN YOU'RE EARLY. THE
BILL ALSO CAN INCLUDE CONFORMITY
TO FEDERAL TAX TREATMENT OF
RESTAURANT REVITALIZATION FUND.
AND SHATTERED VENUE OPERATOR
GRASS AND WHAT THAT MEANS IS ANY
ELIGIBLE CALIFORNIA RESTAURANT
OR VENUE THAT RECEIVED A
FEDERAL- IT MAY DEDUCT EXPENSES
RELATED TO THE BRAND FOR THE
PURPOSES OF STATE TAXES. THE
BILL FOR THE SUPPORT SMALL
BUSINESSES THAT INCLUDES ONE
HUNDRED FIFTY MILLION GENERAL
FUND FOR THE OFFICE OF THE SMALL
BUSINESS ADVOCATE WHICH- WHICH-
WHICH IS WITHIN THE- OFFICE OF
BUSINESS AND ECONOMIC
DEVELOPMENT. TO FIND ELIGIBLE
WAITLISTED. RAMIFICATIONS FROM
PREVIOUS ROUNDS OF THE
CALIFORNIA SMALL BUSINESS COBIT
NINETEEN RELIEF GRANT PROGRAM-
AND THE BILL ALSO EXPANDS THE
ELECTED PASS THROUGH ENTITY TAX
WHICH WAS INCLUDED IN THE TWENTY
TWENTY ONE BUDGET ACT AND ALLOWS
CALIFORNIA TAXPAYERS TO REDUCE
THEIR FEDERAL. TAX BURDEN
WITHOUT REDUCING REVENUES TO THE
STATE. AND MOVING ONTO THE
BUDGET BILL JUNIOR THIS IS
ASKING ONE FIFTEEN AND THIS BILL
INCLUDES SEVERAL PROVISIONS THAT
AMEND THE TWENTY TWENTY ONE BUT
- BEGINNING WITH KOBE COST THE
BUDGET BILL INCLUDES AT. ALL-
DIRECT RESPONSE COSTS THAT ARE
ABOVE THE ONE POINT SEVEN FIVE
BILLION INCLUDED IN THE TWENTY
TWENTY ONE BUDGET ACT BRINGING
THAT TOTAL TO TWO POINT SIX FIVE
BILLION. OR ONE POINT NINE
BILLION ABOVE INCLUDED IN THE
BUDGET ACT FOR THE COMPANY. WHAT
SPECIFICALLY THIS BILL. BILLIONS
THE LEAGUE CALIFORNIA EMERGENCY
BELIEVED FOR THREE STATE
DEPARTMENTS THAT'S ONE POINT SIX
BILLION FOR THE DEPARTMENT OF
PUBLIC HEALTH AND THAT'S LOOKS
LIKE FOR TESTING VACCINATIONS
MEDICAL SURGE- CONTACT TRACING
OPERATIONS SUPPORT AND BORDER
RESPONSE OPERATIONS. ANOTHER TWO
HUNDRED MILLION TWENTY SIX
MILLION FOR THE DEPARTMENT OF
CORRECTIONS. AND REHABILITATION
FOR STATEWIDE TESTING OF OUR
INCARCERATED INVENT INDIVIDUALS
AS WELL AS STAFF. AND ONE
HUNDRED MILLION THE OFFICE OF
EMERGENCY SERVICES FOR
ADDITIONAL PERSONAL PROTECTIVE
EQUIPMENT- AND OTHER DURABLE
MEDICAL GOODS. THESE FUNDS WILL
BE SUBJECT TO THE TRANSPARENCY
PROVISIONS OF CONTROL SECTION
ELEVEN POINT NINE ONE OF THE
TWENTY TWENTY ONE BUDGET ACT
WHICH- REQUIRES A TEN DAY
NOTIFICATION TO. SEE JOINT
LEGISLATIVE BUDGET. COMMITTEE
FOR ANY TRANSFERS MADE. I'M A
FIRM BELIEVER THIS BILL PROVIDES
LONG TO THE STATE RENTALS PER.
AND A LOT OF FOR LOCAL CHURCH.
OPERATING RENTAL ASSISTANCE
PROGRAMS THESE LOANS WILL START
BRANCH FOR THE STATE AND LOCAL
JURISDICTIONS TO CONTINUE TO
DISTRIBUTE RENTAL ASSISTANCE TO
ELIGIBLE CALIFORNIANS. WHO
SUBMIT COMPLETED APPLICATIONS BY
THE END OF MARCH OF THIS YEAR.
I'M SORRY. AND ACTION SHALL
FEDERAL FUNDING BEING MADE
AVAILABLE FOR THIS PURPOSE. BOB
THIS BILL ALSO ALLOCATES THIRTY
MILLION GENERAL FUND TO SUPPORT
INCREASED COSTS PRIMARILY OF.
MEETING BELGIAN AIRING AND
INSTALLATION OF TECHNOLOGY
NECESSARY TO REDUCE EMISSIONS OR
ENERGY GENERATORS YOUR DURING
THE TWENTY TWENTY ONE ENERGY
EMERGENCY TO COMPLY WITH AIR
QUALITY PERMITS. THIS BILL
INCLUDES ONE POINT SIX MILLION
GENERAL FUND- TO IMPLEMENT THE
DEPARTMENT OF PUBLIC HEALTH.
PROGRAM CONSISTENT WITH THE
REQUIREMENTS OF AB FORTY FIVE.
THIS BILL EXEMPTS ANY INCOME
RECEIVED FROM THE CALIFORNIA
ARREARS PAYMENT PROGRAM
ESTABLISHED IN THE TWENTY TWENTY
ONE FOR THE PURPOSES OF STATE
INCOME TAXES FOR INDIVIDUALS AND
BUSINESSES AND FOR THE
DETERMINATION OF ELIGIBILITY FOR
STATE. PROGRAMS FOR CHILD CARE
THIS BILL SUPPORTS PARKING COSTS
RELATED TO ADMINISTERING
SUPPLEMENTAL PAYMENTS TO
PROVIDERS AND GENERAL CHILD CARE
PROGRAMS INCLUDED IN THE TWENTY.
BUDGET ACT. AND IT PROVIDES
TEMPORARY SUPPLEMENTAL PAYMENTS
TO LICENSED CHILDCARE PROVIDERS-
ACCEPTING BATTERS AND FUNDING
FOR COSTS RELATED TO MINISTERING
TO DISTRIBUTION OF SUPPLEMENTAL
PAYMENTS. AND FINALLY THE BILL
INCLUDES A SHIFT FROM FEDERAL
AMERICAN RESCUE PLAN ACT OR
FUNDS TO THE GENERAL FUND OR
OTHER FUNDS TO MAXIMIZE
FLEXIBILITY. AND STREAMLINED
FEDERAL REPORTING. UP MOVING ON
- TRAILER BILL SB ONE SIXTEEN
HUMAN SERVICES TRAILER WELL.
THIS BILL INCLUDES AN
APPROPRIATION OF TWENTY SEVEN
POINT FIVE MILLION GENERAL FUND
FOR IT ADMINISTRATIVE COSTS TO
DISTRIBUTE SUPPLEMENTAL PAYMENTS
TO FAMILY CHILD CARE PROVIDERS
INCLUDED IN THE TWENTY TWENTY
ONE BUDGET ACTION. IT ALSO MAKE
AMENDS TO ALLOW FOR INCREASED
FLEXIBILITY FOR THE DEPARTMENT
OF SOCIAL SERVICES IN ALLOCATING
FEDERAL REFUGEE RESETTLEMENT
FUNDING RELATED TO AFGHAN RIVALS
AND LASTLY. THE SPELLING PLACE
TECHNICAL CLEAN UP REGARDING A
CHAPTER HAVE ISSUE. BOB LIVING
TO THE LAST BELL SB ONE
SEVENTEEN IS THE MEMORANDUM OF
UNDERSTANDING A DENTAL. CAL THE
BILL RATIFIES AGREEMENTS ENTERED
INTO BY THE STATE WITH SEVERAL
BARGAINING UNITS AND RELATED TO
TELEWORK MONTHLY STIPENDS. THE
SECOND PROGRAM IS PART OF THE
ADMINISTRATION'S OVERALL EFFORTS
TO BUILD EFFICIENCIES FOR
DEPARTMENTS AND EMPLOYEES-
DEPARTMENT EMPLOYEES IN THE
HYBRID WORK ENVIRONMENT THAT WE
NOW FIND OURSELVES IN- AS A
RESULT OF THE CODE PENTOMIC. THE
BARGAINING UNITS INCLUDED IN
THIS BILL ARE FOR ATTORNEYS
ADMINISTRATIVE LAW JUDGES AND
HEARING OFFICERS STATE LAW
ENFORCEMENT PROFESSIONAL%
ENGINEERS PROFESSIONAL
SCIENTISTS. OFTEN MAINTENANCE
ENGINEERS AND STATIONING
STATIONARY ENGINEERS. THE BILL
APPROPRIATES TWENTY SEVEN MIL
I'M GOING FOR THE STIPENDS. AND
WITH THAT THAT IS- THE END OF
THE PRESENTATION- ON THE FIVE
BILLS THANK. I THANK YOU HELLO.
GOOD MORNING- CHAIR MEMBERS
CAROLINE CHIU FROM LA- WE ARE
HERE AND AVAILABLE FOR QUESTIONS
. THANK YOU. LET'S GO TO THE
COMMITTEE IN THE COMMENTS MR
FALL. I THANK YOU AS CHAIR I'LL
JUST RUN THROUGH ALL THE- THE
BILL'S AND AS ALL MY QUESTIONS-
THAT WAY- ON- STARTING WITH AB
EIGHTY FOUR OR- SB ONE THIRTEEN-
SO PRIOR TO RACE IT'S IN THIS
DEPARTMENT FINANCE VIBRATIONS OF
THIS- PAID SICK LEAVE WERE
SUPPORTED BY FEDERAL TAX
CREDITS- TO HELP EMPLOYERS.
OFFSET THE COST OF ABSENT
EMPLOYEES AND THAT FEDERAL TAX
CREDIT HAS EXPIRED- IN THIS
PROPOSAL IMPOSES A NEW PAID SICK
LEAVE MANDATE- WITHOUT- THE
FINANCIAL SUPPORT ON THE FEDERAL
SIDE WITH THE STATE SIDE WAYS
THEIR CONVERSATIONS. ABOUT
PROVIDING THE STATE A STATE TAX
CREDIT TO OFFSET THE COSTS.
THANKS FOR BONTA ACQUISITION- IS
SO YOU'RE RIGHT THIS THE CURRENT
ITERATION OF PAID SICK LEAVE
DOES NOT INCLUDE- AIMS. AT ITS
THAT CREDIT WAS PROVIDED BY THE
FEDERAL GOVERNMENT- AND NOT THE
STATE IN THE PRIOR ITERATION-
AND I THINK SOME OF THE
CONSIDERATIONS THAT- ARE ON THE
TABLE ARE JUST THE DIFFICULT IN
REGARDS IMPLEMENTATION AS WELL
AS THE POTENTIAL COSTS. SO THOSE
ARE THINGS THAT ARE. YOU KNOW
THAT THAT IS NOT ROOTED IN THIS
PROPOSAL BUT I WOULD JUST ADD
THAT THSE ARE SOME ISSUES FOR
CONSIDERATION. WELL I THINK
THAT'S THE BROADER QUESTION
RIGHT I MEAN I'M A EMPLOYERS I
MEAN THEY'RE THEY'RE IN THE SAME
ENVIRONMENT AS AS EMPLOYEES OF
THE ON THE CRIME THE THAT THE
WORKFORCE CHALLENGES- MEAN WAS
WHAT WAS THE COST- IT WOULD IS
IT WAS THERE AND ALICE'S SON ON.
QUOTE UNQUOTE THE COSTS THE
FED'S INCA ANCHORED THE
PREFERRED THOSE WHO PARTICIPATED
IN THE PROTEST CREDIT. WHAT HOW
MUCH THAT WAS AND COULD WE- DO
THE SAME INVESTMENT IN THE STATE
SIDE MADE WE HAVE THOSE NUMBERS
. THERE IS NO SUCH STUDY TO MY
KNOWLEDGE. SIGN ON THE COST TO
PRIVATE EMPLOYERS AS A RESULT OF
THAT- TAX CREDIT. MAYBE I CAN AS
THE L. A. L. IT WAS THERE WAS
THERE DO YOU HAVE AN A AN
ESTIMATE ON WHAT THE **** BUT
THE FISCAL IMPACT WOULD BE A
CREATING A STATE CREDIT HAD TO
MAYOR THE FOR. THE EXPIRED
FEDERAL CREDIT. YES IT YEAH IN
RESPONSE TO A REQUEST FROM
BUDGET STAFF WE DID PUT TOGETHER
AN ESTIMATE OF WHAT A STATE TAX
CREDIT. TO COVER THE COSTS-
FACED Y EMPLOYERS COULD LOOK
LIKE. I WILL NOTE THAT THE
ESTIMATE IS SUBJECT TO A FAIR
AMOUNT OF UNCERTAINTY- GIVEN THE
VARIOUS FACTORS THAT WE HAVE TO
CONSIDER AND I CAN GET SOME
MILES ON JUST A SECOND. WE BASE
OUR ESTIMATES OVERALL ON. A
STUDY OF WHAT THE FEDERAL. TAX
CREDIT COSTS BY THE DEPARTMENT
OF THE TREASURY. OUR ESTIMATES
FOR THAT EIGHT TAX CREDIT AT THE
STATE LEVEL- TO- STARTED BEING
OF THE YEAR TO SEPTEMBER. COST
BETWEEN FIVE HUNDRED MILLION AND
ONE POINT FOUR BILLION DOLLARS
TO THE STATE. IMPORTANTLY WE
CREATED THESE. ESTIMATES BEFORE
THE BILL WAS AND PRINT- AND SO
THOSE THESE ESTIMATES MAY NOT
ALIGN PERFECTLY. WITH THE
PARAMETERS OF THE BILL. ALSO
NOTE THAT ARE ESTIMATES ARE
CREDIT ON A NUMBER OF
ASSUMPTIONS INCLUDING HOW MANY
EMPLOYERS- PROVIDED THE SICK
LEAVE PRIOR TO THE ENACTMENT OF
THE BILL IN THERE FOR WOULD
CLAIM. THE CREDIT DURING THE
PEAK OF THE SEARCH. I IN JANUARY
AND FEBRUARY JUST I JANUARY-
AND ALSO DEPENDENT ON. IF YOU
READ HISTORY AT PRECEDING THE
REST OF THE YEAR SO IT SO IT IS
QUITE VARIABLE BUT SAID TO SUM
UP WE DID WE DID RUN LAST NIGHT
AND- CAME UP WITH BETWEEN FIVE
HUNDRED MILLION MONTHLY FOR
BILLIONS. SO GOING BACK TO THE
DEPARTMENT OF FINANCE. IS I JUST
WANT TO MAKE SURE I GET THIS
CORRECTLY RIGHT LEG WE
UNDERSTAND WHAT'S HAPPENING THE
- LET'S STIPULATE THAT THE
RANGERS FIVE HUNDRED MILLION TO
ONE POINT FOUR BILLION- THAT
COSTS WOULD BE INCURRED BY.
EMPLOYERS IN CALIFORNIA WITH NO
OFFSET. HAVING NOT SEEN THE L.
A. ANALYSIS I'M I AM NOT SURE I
CAN RESPOND TO THAT I THINK THAT
THERE ARE LOTS OF VARIABLES TO
BE CONSIDERED. SHE STATED- AND
SO THE POTENTIAL CHANGE COULD BE
QUITE HIGH. WELL OKAY LOOK LET'S
JUST LET'S JUST MAKE THE TAKE A
STEP BACK AND SAY WITHOUT THERE
IS NO FEDERAL TAX CREDIT YOU
STIPULATED THAT. SO THE COST OF
THIS PROPOSAL WILL BE BORNE BY.
BUSINESSES IN CALIFORNIA WITH NO
OFFSET WHAT. SO THE BUSINESS'S
BLADE BEAR THAT I WOULD JUST ADD
THAT THERE ARE THERE IS AN
EXCEPTION INCLUDED IT WAS ALL
PART IN PLAYERS WITH UNDER-
TWENTY FIVE EMPLOYEES AND I
WOULD ALSO POINT TO MANY.
SUPPORTS THAT YOU HAVE PROVIDED
AT THE STATE AND THE FEDERAL
LEVEL TO BUSINESS. INCLUDED IT'S
UP SOME OF THOSE SOME OF THOSE
ARE ACTUALLY INCLUDED IN THE
EARLY ACTION AS WELL AS THE
GOVERNOR HAS STATED THAT WE WILL
CONTINUE. TO LOOK FOR OTHER WAYS
IN WHICH SUPPORTS BUSINESSES
SMALL BUSINESSES IN PARTICULAR
THAT HAVE BEEN MOST IMPACTED BY
COULD BE NINETEEN. SHE WELL I
MEAN IF THE L. L. I KNOW WE'RE
JUST DISPUTING THAT THE NUMBERS
BUT THE ALEJO'S ANALYSIS WAS ON
WITH THE FEDERAL TAX CREDITS OF
THE EXEMPTION YOU WHAT WHERE YOU
GUYS ARE EXTENDING- THE PREVIOUS
IMAGE BASE IT IS IT IS THE
EXTENSION OF THE PREVIOUS- BILL
THAT WAS DONE LEGISLATURE. SO
THAT EXEMPTION ORDER EXISTS SO
WHATEVER CAUGHT SO WHATEVER COST
WAS INCURRED. IN THE PREVIOUS
BILL WOULD BE INCURRED AGAIN BUT
WOULD NOW WOULD KNOW OFFSET-
THAT IS CORRECT AND AGAIN I
WOULD POINT TO SOME OF THE OTHER
SUPPORTS ARE OUTSIDE. I'M THAT
WE ARE PROVIDING TO SMALL
BUSINESSES BUT YES THAT IS
CORRECT OKAY. I WAS ONE MAKE
SURE THAT THE THAT THE FUTURE OR
THE OTHER OR TAX RELIEF IS
APPLES TO ORANGES RIGHT IT'S NOT
IT'S NOT RELATED TO- THE OFFSET
OF THE COSTS. BUT JUMPING TO-
BUT BEFORE TO TALK ON THIS TOPIC
I THINK- WHEN THE SPEAKER THE
PRO TEM THE GOVERNOR SHOULD
STATEMENT- YOU KNOW WE AGREE
WITH YOUR- YOUR OINT AND WE
THINK THAT. AS PART OF OUR JUNE
BUDGET DISCUSSIONS THAT WE
SHOULD REALLY LOOK AT. SOME
POTENTIAL GRANTS OR TAX RELIEF I
IN PARTICULAR FOR SMALL
BUSINESSES BECAUSE WE ARE
CONCERNED. ABOUT THE POTENTIAL
IMPACT ON THOSE BUSINESSES SO I
THINK THAT- WHILE THAT'S NOT IN
THIS PACKAGE I THINK THE
ASSEMBLY DEFINITELY. I WANT TO
CONTINUE THE DISCUSSION IN THE
JUNE DISCUSSIONS- ESPECIALLY IN
REGARDS TO HAVING A VERY.
SPECIFIC FOCUS ON SMALL
BUSINESSES AND I APPRECIATE THE
COMMISSION THIS YEAR I THINK- HE
ACKNOWLEDGES AS WELL AS I THAT
WHAT WE'RE HEARING FROM THE
SMALL BUSINESSES WHO ARE
PERSEVERING THROUGH THE PANDEMIC
IS THAT. WE'RE PLACING THE
SECTOR THAT THE LEGISLATURE IS
PLACING MORE BURDENS ON THEM AND
THIS IS- A SIGNIFICANT COST
BURDEN THAT IT HAS NO OFFSET AND
I THINK THAT'S WHAT I'M TYING
TO. TO FLUSH OUT- IN MY
QUESTIONING SO I BUT I CERTAINLY
APPRECIATE THAT- SEARCHER.
JUMPING TO- A ADS. SEVEN AND I'M
AB EIGHTY FOUR AND OF THE- I WAS
EIGHTY SEVEN THE ECONOMIC
RELIEF- THE PANDEMIC RELIEF- TO
THE FORMER FINANCE I MY
UNDERSTANDING IS THAT THERE
ISN'T A FULL CONFORMITY WHEN IT
COMES TO- THE SHATTERED VENUES
GRANT PROGRAM. AS WELL AS- OTHER
PROGRAMS WITH- WITHIN THE PPP
PROGRAM- SPECIFICALLY THE
PAYCHECK PROTECTION. LOOK FOR
PROGRAM LOANS AFTER MARCH THIRTY
FIRST OF TWENTY TWENTY ONE- CAN
YOU GIVE ME AN EXPLANATION OF
WHY THERE ISN'T- FULL CONFORMITY
WHEN IT COMES TO THOSE PROGRAMS
. AND THAT'S WHAT I'M- SURE JUST
A NOTE THAT THAT- THAT GAP HAS
COME TO OUR ATTENTION RECENTLY
AND THAT'S SOMETHING THAT WE
HAVE BEEN. DISCUSSING IT IS NOT
INCLUDED IN THIS EARLY ACTION
BUT- WE ARE AWARE OF THAT ISSUE
. OKAY SO THAT THERE IS A HOPE
OF ACTION IN THE FUTURE OF
ADDRESSING THAT GAP SO THAT
THERE IS- FOR CONFORMITY MY
CONCERN IS THAT- WE'RE TRYING TO
GET THIS. DONE BY THE MARCH
FIFTEENTH FILING OF TAXES BY BY
A LOT OF OUR- VENUES AND
BUSINESSES SO ITI JUST WANNA
MAKE SURE THAT WE- WEAR A
KNOWLEDGE AND THAT THERE IS A
TIME A TIMING ISSUE. YES AGAIN
THAT THAT IS MORE MORE RECENTLY
BROUGHT TO OUR ATTENTION AND
THAT'S SOMETHING THAT I WILL
BRING IT BACK TO. DISK PROPER
DISCUSSIONS OKAY ON AB ONE FORTY
SEVEN- THE BUDGET BILL JUNIOR-
THERE ARE A NUMBER OF. FUNDS
GOING TO- PREVIOUSLY- APPROVE
CONTRACTS WELL THERE PROCEED NO
BID CONTRACTS- WHAT. WHAT IS THE
PRIMARY FINANCE DOING WHAT CAR
REALIZE YOU HAVE TO ENSURE THAT
THOSE DOLLARS ARE BEING SPENT
EFFECTIVELY. MR GOING ARE YOU
SPEAKING SPECIFICALLY ABOUT A
PARTICULAR CONTRACT. SUSPENSION
VALENCIA LAPS AND THE TO R.
SEVENTEEN MILLION DOLLARS TO
OPERATE THAT I'M ASSUMING THAT
SOME OF THE COVERT RELIEF-
FUNDING REQUESTED BY THE
MINISTRATION IS TO GO TO FIND
THAT CONTRACT TO CONTINUE TO
FIND THAT CONTRACT- THAT IS
CORRECT- AT THE VOLUNTEER
CONTRACTED. I WOULD- POINT OUT A
FORTY FIVE DAY CLOUDS AND- YEAH
BUT EVERY EVERY IF- THAT VENDOR-IS FOUND TO BE NOT PERFORMING
THE STATE HAS A RIGHT TO
TERMINATE THAT CONTRACT WITH
FORTY FIVE DAY NOTICE I JUST
WANTED TO POINT THAT OUT THERE
THAT IS A GUARD RAIL- LIKE MANY
CONTRACTS AT THE STATE- PROCURE
IS. THERE ARE- PROTECTIONS SO
THAT THE STATE IS THAT HELD
LIABLE FOR- ISSUES WITH THE
VENDOR THAT IS JUST ONE THING.
I'D LIKE TO POINT OUT- IT'S NOT
MY AND AS WELL THAT THERE ARE
DISCUSSIONS- GOING ON RIGHT NOW
IN REGARDS TO OTHER CONTRACTS SO
JUST POINT THAT OUT. SO THEN HOW
DOES HOW DOES THE- PART OF
THOSE- GUARDRAILS OPERATE DOES
THE THERE'S A DEPARTMENT THEY
NOTIFY YOU THAT EVERY FORTY FIVE
DAYS OR I'M JUST I UNDERSTAND
LIKE. WHAT THIS THIS ONE POINT
NINE MILLION DOLLARS AND I KNOW
THAT THE CHAIR AND THE
LEGISLATURE HAS. PUSH FOR THIS
PROCESS- THE MOVING TO THE
BUDGET COMMITTEE FOR THIS VERY
REASON RIGHT THAT THERE NEEDS TO
BE TRANSPARENCY AND HOW WE- HELL
OUT THESE FUNDS ARE BEING
ALLOCATED NOW THEY'RE BEING USED
AND WHETHER THEY'RE BEING USED
EFFECTIVELY. AND WE'RE NOT USING
THE OTHER PROCESSES THAT WERE
DONE- DURING THE PANDEMIC SO I'M
JUST TRYING TO UNDERSTAND WHAT I
OF THE ONE POINT NINE MILLION.
AND THAT IS WITH A B. WICKS WHAT
CHECK WHAT GUARDRAILS THERE ARE
THERE TO ENSURE THAT. IT'S NOT
BEING WASTED. I'M SURE IN
REGARDS TO PROCESS I WILL TURN
THAT QUESTION OVER TO ONE OF MY
COLLEAGUES- FOR SOME DETAILS.
NOVATEL WITH THE DEPARTMENT OF
FINANCE AND- THAT'S SOMETHING
THAT WE CAN TAKE BACK FOR A
LITTLE BIT MORE INFORMATION BUT
TO JUST REITERATE MISLEADS POINT
TO THERE ARE SPECIFIC GUARDRAILS
WITHIN THE CONTRACTS THAT ALLOW
THE DEPARTMENT TO TERMINATE THE
CONTRACT WITHIN FORTY FIVE DAYS.
WE'D ALSO LIKE TO NOTE THAT THE
DEPARTMENT IS ALSO. CURRENTLY IN
THE PROCESS OF REVIEWING OTHER
LABORATORIES INCLUDING THE UC
SYSTEM. FOR ADDITIONAL SUPPORT
IN TIMES WHEN WE NEED TO RAPIDLY
INCREASE OUR TESTING AND AS A
PATH EVENTUAL RELEASE FILES IN
THE EVENT WE DO UP TO TERMINATE
OUR CONTRACT WITH- THE VALENCIA
BRANDS LAB. OKAY BUT YOU'RE-
YOU'RE GIVING ME FUTURE ACTIONS
BUT WE'RE FINDING SOMETHING NOW.
SO WHAT IS THE ONE POINT NINE
BILLION BEING USED FOR. SO THE
ONE POINT NINE BILLION IS- AND
LET ME JUST POINT OUT THAT WE
ARE BRINGING THIS BEFORE YOU AS
PART OF A BUDGET PROCESS THAT
IT'S NOT GOING THROUGH- WHAT
THAT YOUR MENTION WAS A DISASTER
RESPONSE EMERGENCY OPERATIONS
ACCOUNT- OR THROUGH. JOINT
LEGISLATIVE BUDGET LETTER THIS
IS SOMETHING THAT WE- MIGHT TO
PROVIDE TRANSPARENCY TO THE
LEGISLATURE AND THEREFORE GOING
TO THE BUDGET PROCESS- BUT IN
REGARDS TO THE ONE POINT NINE
BILLION- IT IS LARGELY- THREE
DEPARTMENTS- I MENTIONED EARLIER
THAT. THE CALIFORNIA DEPARTMENT
OF PUBLIC HEALTH HAS ABOUT ONE
POINT SIX BILLION- AND MUCH OF
THAT IS TO PROVIDE SUPPORT FOR
CONTACT TRACING HOSPITAL MEDICAL
SEARCH OUR OWN STATE OPERATIONS.
STATE WRESTING VACCINE
DISTRIBUTION- SUPPORT FOR
VULNERABLE POPULATION SO THAT'S
THE LARGEST CHUNK OF THE ONE
POINT BILLION- ANOTHER TWO
HUNDRED. FOR THE CORRECTIONS THE
OF CORRECTIONS REHABILITATION
LARGELY FOR TESTING BOTH OF-
CRASHED INCARCERATED INDIVIDUALS
AS- AND THEN THERE'S A HUNDRED
MILLION ON TOP OF THAT FOR THE
OPERATION- THE OFFICE OF
EMERGENCY- SERVICES AND THAT IS
LARGELY FOR P. P. SO THOSE ARE
THOSE ARE THE SPECIFIC.
CATEGORIES OF FUNDING THAT
REQUIRE QUESTING THAT IS IN
ADDITION TO THE ONE POINT FOUR
FIVE- ONE POINT SEVEN FIVE
BILLION THAT WAS IN THE CURRENT
YEAR. AND I JUST- I THINK PROVES
THE POINT OF HOW- HOW MUCH ALL
RIGHT WE DIDN'T KNOW ADD TO THAT
THE THAT BUDGET ACTS IN JULY
WHEN- THE BILL WHEN IT TOOK.
ADULTO WAS NOT THE MAY HAVE BEEN
ON HER EYES ON THE CRIME WAS NOT
- AND SO THIS IS. A THE STATE'S
RESPONSE. PUBLIC HEALTH. IN IT-
THAT HAVE LARGELY BEEN- EXPANDED
TO MORE INDIVIDUALS AND WE NEED
FOR THE SUPPORT FOR OUR VACCINE
EFFORTS. WELL IF YOU COULD
PROVIDE US WITH THAT LINE ITEM
I'D- SPECIFICALLY MAY I KNOW YOU
GIVEN HAS BROUGHT BUCKETS BUT IF
THERE'S A LINE ITEM THAT YOU CAN
GIVE US I THINK THAT'S IMPORTANT%
I'VE I'VE BLOOD THE CHAIR FROM
MAKING THIS MAKING. THIS
PROPOSAL GO TO THE BUDGET
COMMITTEE SO THAT WE CAN GET
THOSE DETAILS I THINK THAT'S THE
VERY- THAT'S THAT'S WHAT WE'RE
TRYING TO MAKE IS THAT IT'S
IMPORTANT FOR- THESE PROPOSALS
TO SEE THE LIGHT OF DAY SO THAT
WE KNOW WHAT'S GOING INTO IT
ESPECIALLY WHEN THERE ARE
HUNDREDS OF MILLIONS OF DOLLARS.
THAT HAVE GONE INTO NO BID
CONTRACTS THAT WE DON'T KNOW
WHAT THOSE GUARDRAILS ARE YOU
MENTION CARD REELS PLURAL BUT
YOU ONLY MENTION ONE GUARDRAIL
WHICH IS THE FORTY FIVE DAY
REVIEW SO THERE ARE OTHER
GUARDRAILS WE CERTAINLY LIKE TO
HEAR WHAT THOSE ARE- IN TERMS.
OF THE- THAT THE ONE HUNDRED
SEVENTY WILL- THE THIRTY MILLION
DOLLARS TO ENSURE THESE- THIRTY
THESE FOR THIRTY MEGAWATT
GENERATORS THAT WERE PURCHASED
MEET- AIR QUALITY STANDARDS- I
GUESTS IS TO SAVE THE THIRTY
MILLION WOULD AND IT JUST MAKES
SENSE TO HAVE THE STATE AND THE
FEDERAL. I HAVE THE STATE ASK
FOR THE STATE AND THE FEDERAL
GOVERNMENT TO WAIVE- OR WAVE OR
ALLOW THESE- TO GET SOME WAIVERS
TO IT TO ENSURE THAT THESE MEGA
WATT GENERATORS ON COMPLIANCE.
YEAH FOR MORE SPECIFICS I'M NOT
ASSEMBLY MEMBER FONG I WILL TURN
OVER TO A COLLEAGUE. YEAH GOOD
MORNING TURN MEMBERS- THIRTY
RATHER PART OF FINANCE AT THOUGH
REALLY KIND OF THE CARD
GENERATOR IF YOU NATURAL GAS. AS
THOUGH. IT PORTANTINO THAT YOU
KIND OF ONE OF THE KEY GOALS.
WHEN WE PUT THE GENERATOR PRETTY
EMERGENT DURING THE SUMMER- WE
RECEIVED A WAIVER I'VE BECAUSE
WE DID NOT HAVE. HI I GOOD THE
PROCESS TO MAKE SURE THAT THE
GENERATORS- WE'RE KIND OF UP TO
CODE IN TERMS OF MEETING
ADMISSION REQUIREMENTS THOUGH I
THINK YOU KNOW WE'RE ALL
PREVENTATIVE TO AIR POLLUTION
NAY AND THOSE COMMUNITIES WHERE
THOSE GENERATORS ARE. AT THE BY
INSTALLING THE ADVANCED
TECHNOLOGY EQUIPMENT ON THE
GENERATOR TO. HELP THE POOR- OUT
OF THEIR MEETING AIR QUALITY
REQUIREMENTS AND ALSO- BE
CREATING ANY KIND OF AIR. I WILL
REFRAIN MY RHETORICAL QUESTION
ABOUT WHY IN A TIME OF CRISIS
THE GOVERNOR WHILE CRITIQUING
NATURAL GAS IS BUYING NATURAL
GAS GENERATORS IN THE MIDDLE OF
AN EMERGENCY BUT- IT SEEMS TO ME
THAT- THERE AND THAT. YOU COULD
JUST ASK FOR THE EXTENSION OF
THE WAIVERS AND- SAVE THE STATE
THIRTY MILLION DOLLARS- JUMPING
TO- ACTUALLY WITH THE LAST
QUESTION ON ON THIS BILL IS THE
CREATION OF THIS CALIFORNIA
EMERGENCY RELIEF FUND. IS THERE
A REASON WHY WE'RE CREATING A
NEW PHONE AND INSTEAD OF JUST
USING THE EXISTING FUNDS TO
PROVIDE EMERGENCY RELIEF WHY WHY
CREATE THIS NEW RELIEF FUND.
SURE THIS IS SIMILAR TO THE
RELIEF FUND THAT WAS CREATED IN
LAST YEAR'S BUDGET OF THE
CURRENT YEAR'S BUDGET- FOR THE
GOLDEN STATE STIMULUS FUND. AND-
YOU KNOW THAT FUND WAS WAS
CREATED FOR A MARGIN SEE RELIEF
RELATED EXPENSES- AND THERE WERE
PROVISIONS AROUND THAT SO. IT
DIDN'T MAKE SENSE NECESSARILY TO
USE THAT SAME EMERGENCY FUND BUT
SIMILAR TO THAT INSTANCE WE'RE
BEING CONSISTENT WITH CURRENT
LAW AND THAT ACTIVITY FROM LAST
YEAR AND REALLY TRYING TO.
CREATE WE CREATED THIS EMERGENCY
FUND FOR EMERGENCY RELATED-
ACTIVITIES. SELECT YOUR C. Y.
JUST. ALLOCATED OTHER GENERAL
FUND WHY CREATE EMERGENCY FUND
AT ALL. HE TRACKED THE MONEY
EITHER WAY WHETHER IT COMES FROM
THE FUND OR THE GENERAL FUND WHY
NOT JUST ALLOCATED ON THE
GENERAL FUND. SURE AND THIS IS
CONSISTENT WITH THE ACTIONS
THAT- WE TOOK LAST YEAR THAT
THAT THE ADMINISTRATION PROPOSAL
LEGISLATURE UP STARTLED THE
LEGISLATURE AN ADMINISTRATION
PROPOSED LAST YEAR SO I JUST
WANT TO POINT THAT OUT AND WE
HAVE THE ADDED BENEFIT THAT THIS
COULD BE- IT SOUNDS LITTLE.
EXCLUDABLE AS WELL. SO YOU'RE
TRYING TO MOVE THESE FUNDS FROM.
THE CELL YEAH LIMIT- THAT'S A
POSSIBILITY. THAT COULD BENEFIT-
THE STATE IF THESE FUNDS ARE
PROVIDED THROUGH AN EMERGENCY
ACCOUNT. SO WHY WOULD YOU WANT
IT EXCLUDED- AT. IT IS IT
ACTUALLY IS EXCLUDED FROM THAT-
THE STATE'S- ALLOCATIONS AND
THAT WOULD BENEFIT THE AGAIN
LIMITS. BUT AGAIN WELL WHEN YOU
SAY BENEFIT I MADE THE IF IT'S
OVER THE GAMUT WE WOULD ARGUE
THAT IT SHOULD BE GIVEN BACK
RIGHT SO IF YOU EXCLUDE IT THAT
MEANS THAT MONEY DOESN'T HAVE TO
BE GIVEN BACK. TO THE TO THE
STATE TAXPAYERS OR TO. OTHER
INVESTMENTS. YES AND I WOULD
JUST GET HIGHLIGHTED THIS IS
SOMETHING THAT WE DID LAST YEAR
SO IT'S CONSISTENT WITH. BUT
CURRENT LAW AND THE ACTIONS
THAT- THIS MARCH OF LAST YEAR.
BUT OKAY WELL IT'S GETTING IT'S
CONSISTENT I FIND IT I OPENING
THAT YOU'RE TRYING TO EXCLUDE
CERTAIN SOMETHING FOR YOU TRYING
TO CREATE A FUND TO EXCLUDED OUT
OF SOMETHING THAT. PROBABLY
SHOULDN'T BE EXCLUDED- AND THEN
MY LAST QUESTION MOVING TO- AB
ONE THIRTY NINE- IS- HOW MAY OF
UP. FOR PROFIT ORGANIZATIONS
WILL NOW BE ELIGIBLE FOR THE-
THE FEDERAL GRANT FUNDING- FOR
REFUGEE RESETTLEMENT ASSISTANCE.
AND HOW WITH THE- NONPROFITS IN
COUNTIES BE PRIORITIZED FOR THIS
FUNDING. YES CAN I TURN THAT
QUESTION OVER TO A COLLEAGUE.
YES THANK YOU FOR THE QUESTION
MR FONG THIS IS NOT A CLASSY-
WITH THE DEPARTMENT OF FINANCE-
AS YOU NOTED THE LANGUAGE
REQUIRES THAT THE DEPARTMENT TO-
PRIORITIZE COUNTY NONPROFITS IN
THIS ALLOCATION OF FUNDS- THIS
IS YOU KNOW CONSISTENT WITH
PREVIOUS APPROACH TO THAT
INFRASTRUCTURE IS ALREADY IN
PLACE- WE DON'T HAVE A SPECIFIC
CENTRO NUMBER OF FOR PROFIT
PROVIDERS OR- ABOUT AND WE CAN
CERTAINLY WORK WITH THE
DEPARTMENT TO PROVIDE ADDITIONAL
INFORMATION AND DETAILS OKAY
WELL YOU SAID THERE'S
PRIORITIZATION SO HOW HOW YOU.
ARE YOU PRIORITIZING. AND WE'RE
HAPPY TO FOLLOW UP WITH
ADDITIONAL INFORMATION ON HOW
THE DEPARTMENT WOULD IMPLEMENT
THAT PRIORITIZATION. BUT WE'RE
VOTING ON THIS BILL ON MONDAY OR
NOT- TODAY I MADE HER VOTING ON
THIS WE WERE BEFORE VOTING ON
THIS BILL AND THAT COUPLE HOURS-
HOW ARE YOU GONNA TELL ME IN
ADVANCE. AFTER I BILL ON THE
BILL. FINALLY WELL IT'S TIME TO
GET AS MUCH INFORMATION TO YOU
AS SOON AS POSSIBLE. IN THE END
IN FACT DURING THIS YEAR I WILL
BE TRYING TO GET SOME OF THAT
INFORMATION OKAY I. I DON'T WANT
TO BELABOR THE CONVERSATION BUT
IT IS VERY FRUSTRATING THAT.
WHERE WERE HEARING THESE BILLS
AND WE'RE VOTING THEM ON TODAY
BUT WE CAN'T GET ANY DETAILS
FROM THE ADMINISTRATION WHO
SUPPOSEDLY NEGOTIATED THESE
BILLS. AND SO THAT IS A BROADER
POINT I WOULD MAKE ON THE
PROCESS IS THAT. WE MAKE
DECISIONS ON IN PERFECT
INFORMATION ALL THE TIME YOU'RE
JUST NOT GIVING US ANY
INFORMATION AND THAT'S A PROBLEM. THAT WAS FOR SURE THE NAME
OTHER MEMBERS OF THE COMMITTEE.
NOT NOT SEEING ANY OTHER MEMBERS
OF THE COMMITTEE OKAY LET'S GO
TO PUBLIC COMMENT. YOU HAVE ONE
MINUTE PLEASE- TAKES. THANK YOU
MISTER CHAIR. WE HAVE THE
MICHAEL PLEASE. SEVEN THERE WE
GO. NO NO WITH THIS MICROPHONE
ON.
YES GOOD THANK YOU. THANK
YOU YES THANK YOU MISTER
CHAIRMAN BIRDS ARE A PART OF
MARTINEZ WITH THE CALIFORNIA
LABOR FEDERATION- HERE IN STRONG
SUPPORT OF THE PROPOSAL'S AROUND
COVERT SICK LEAVE- A. B. EIGHTY
FOUR AND SB ONE FOURTEEN WHEN I
THINK THE ADMINISTRATION VERY
MUCH FOR THEIR EARLY ACTION-
SORT OF LEADING INTO THIS ISSUE
IT'S OBVIOUSLY VITALLY IMPORTANT
FOR OUR MEMBERS. I ALSO THINK
THIS COMMITTEE FOR THEIR
ATTENTION THIS AND PARTICULARLY-
SOME OF WOMAN CARILLO FOR HER
HELP AND GUIDANCE AND NEVER
GETTING THIS ISSUE I THINK SO
MUCH WE ASK FOR YOUR SUPPORT.
THANK YOU LET'S GO TO THE NEXT
BIGGER. GOOD MORNING MR CHAIRMAN
MEMBERS GOOD TO SEE HIM AT
CERTAIN THE CALIFORNIA
RESTAURANT ASSOCIATION WE ARE IN
SUPPORT OF AB EIGHTY SEVEN IN
PARTICULAR WITH REGARD TO THE-
RESTAURANT RIVER REVITALIZATION
FUNDS. THOSE WERE REALLY
LIFELINE FUNDS FROM THE FEDERAL
GOVERNMENT- TO HELP OFFSET FOR
THE GOVERNMENT ORDERED CLOSURES
OF RESTAURANTS. AND SO ONE THING
I WOULD SAY IS THOSE WERE NEVER
INTENDED- ON A BIPARTISAN BASIS
TO BE TAXED AS INCOME THIS
ENSURES THAT THEY WON'T. AND
THEN THE OTHER THING JUST TO
KEEP IN MIND IS THOSE REALLY
FUNDS WENT 2404% OF CALIFORNIA'S
QUALIFIED RESTAURANTS SO THE
VAST MAJORITY OF CALIFORNIA
RESTAURANTS DIDN'T GET THAT
RELIEF BUT FOR THOSE THAT DID
THE LUCKY ONES. THIS IS THE
TIPPING POINT PROBABLY FOR
WHETHER THEY CAN REMAIN A VIABLE
EMPLOYER OR NOT SO WE ARE GREAT
SUPPORT AND THANK YOU FOR YOUR
SUPPORT. THANK YOU. GOOD MORNING
MR CHAIRMAN FIRST CHRISTMAS
CEILIDH ON BEHALF OF THE
HOLLYWOOD CHAMBER OF COMMERCE
WERE THANKFUL TO THE
ADMINISTRATION AND BOTH HOUSES
OF THE LEGISLATURE FOR AB EIGHTY
SEVEN AND ARE IN STRONG SUPPORT
FIRST THAT YOU ELIMINATE THE
THIRD YEAR OF THE CAP ON THE USE
OF BUSINESS TAX CREDITS AND THE
SUSPENSION OF THE NET OPERATING
LOSS DEDUCTION AND SECONDLY THE
CONFORMITY NOT JUST ON THE
RESTAURANT REVITALIZATION FUND
BUT ALSO ON THE SHUTTERED VENUE
PROVIDER TAX CONFORMITY AS WELL.
THANK YOU. GREAT I GOT ONE
COMMITTEE MEMBER WANTED TO MAKE
A COMMENTS WE'RE GONNA GO BACK
TO MISS KOREA. AND THEN I WILL
WHILE SHE GETS READY TO COMMENT
JUST REMIND EVERYONE. IF THEY
WANNA MAKE A COMMENT BY PHONE
THEY CAN CALL TO THE PHONE LINE
EIGHT SEVEN SEVEN SIX NINE TWO
EIGHT NINE FIVE SEVEN. PUBLIC
ACCESS CODE IS ONE THREE ONE
FIVE FOUR TWO OH TWO THANK YOU.
THANK YOU MISTER CHAIR APOLOGIES
GOT A LITTLE DISTRACTED. I YOU
KNOW I JUST WANT TO THANK
EVERYONE INVOLVED THINK BUDGET
STAFF THE DEPARTMENT OF FINANCE
PHILLY- THE ADMINISTRATION YOU
MISTER CHAIR AND- ALL OF THE
MEMBERS INVOLVED IN PUSHING
FORWARD. THE EXTENSION OF COVERT
SICK LEAVE WE'RE LIVING THROUGH
UNPRECEDENTED TIMES. WE EXPANDED
LAST YEAR WITH ADDITIONAL
SUPPORT FROM THE FEDERAL
GOVERNMENT. WE SAW A SURGE IN
OMICRON ANOTHER VARIANCE.
PUTTING THE HEALTH OF. EVERYDAY
PEOPLE ACROSS CALIFORNIA AND
JEOPARDY AND WE'RE TRYING TO
FIND SOLUTIONS AS WE TRY TO
FIGURE THIS OUT ALL OF US. AND I
THINK WE'VE COME TO A GOOD- THE
GOOD PLACE- ESPECIALLY WITH
REGARDS TO THE SMALL BUSINESSES
AS WELL WO NEED A LOT OF
SUPPORT TO MAINTAIN. OTHER
BUSINESSES OPEN AND FOR THE MOST
PART WE ALL AGREE ARE THE-
BACKBONE OF OUR COMMUNITIES WE
THINK ABOUT SMALL BUSINESSES AND
HOW. THEY'RE ABLE TO LOCALLY
EMPLOYED PROVIDE OPPORTUNITIES.
NO ONE NO WORKER WHETHER IN A
LARGE BUSINESS OR SMALL BUSINESS
SHOULD HAVE TO MAKE. THE REALLY
TOUGH DECISION OF EITHER. GOING
TO WORK SICK- AND JEOPARDIZING
THEIR OWN HEALTH AND THE HEALTH
OF THEIR COWORKERS OR AT NOT
BEING ABLE TO PAY THEIR RENT AS
SCHOOLS HAVE REOPENED CHILDREN
ARE ALSO. AT PLAY HERE WITH MANY
KIDS COMING HOME TESTING%
POSITIVE AND PARENTS HAVING TO
MAKE. THE VERY DIFFICULT-
CHOICES OF HOW TO TAKE CARE OF
THEIR FAMILIES THEMSELVES AND
ULTIMATELY BE ABLE TO. LIVE IN
INDIGNITY PAY THEIR RENT TO PAY
THEIR MORTGAGE AND TRY TO
SURVIVE WE HAVE ALL EXPERIENCED
THAT AND WE KNOW THAT COLD THAT
HAS HIT. DIFFERENT COMMUNITIES
IN DIFFERENT WAYS MARGINALIZED
COMMUNITIES LOW WAGE WORKERS LOW
INCOME COMMUNITIES HAVE SUFFERED
THE MOST ACROSS THE STATE- WE
HAVE FELT THAT AND SO I THINK
THAT WE ARE DOING THE RIGHT
THING. I'M GRATEFUL FOR THE
BUSINESS COMMUNITY THAT CAME
TOGETHER TO SUPPORT I KNOW THAT
WE'RE GOING TO FIND ADDITIONAL
SOLUTIONS- IN THIS YEAR'S BUDGET
TO ENSURE THAT. SMALL BUSINESSES
THAT HAVE BEEN ACCEPTED BUT ALSO
NEED ADDITIONAL SUPPORT HAVE
THAT AND TO- THE RESTAURANT
ASSOCIATION'S POINT FIGURE OUT A
WAY IN WHICH WE SUPPORT- THE
RESTAURANT IN OUR COMMUNITY THAT
WE ALL LOVE. AND THAT WE WANT TO
MAKE SURE THAT THEY STAY OPEN
THEY CONTINUE TO EMPLOY. AND
THAT ULTIMATELY PUT PEOPLE FIRST
SO THAT NO ONE HAS TO MAKE A
DECISION. WHETHER IT'S THEIR
HEALTH OR THEIR ABILITY TO PAY
THEIR RENT THIS IS THE- THE
AWESOME RESPONSIBILITY THAT WE
ALL HAVE AT THIS MOMENT TO
ENSURE THAT WERE ABLE TO MOVE
FORWARD TOGETHER. FOR THE FORTY
MILLION PEOPLE THAT CALL
CALIFORNIA HOME SO JUST WANT TO
SAY THAT IT'S BEEN CHALLENGING
IT'S BEEN DIFFICULT AS BUT I
OPENING. BUT I'M GLAD THAT WE'RE
IN A GOOD PLACE SOMEWHERE ABLE
TO MOVE FORWARD FOR THE PEOPLE
OF CALIFORNIA THANK YOU. I THANK
YOU AS A MEMBER CARILLO
UTTERBACK OVER THE CHAIR. ANY
OTHER COMMENTS FROM THE
COMMITTEE. SEE NOW WE'RE GOING
TO GO TO PUBLIC COMMENT SINGLE
PUBLIC COMMENT IN THE HEARING
ROOM LET'S GO TO PHONE LINES
OPERATOR WITH REPUBLICANS-
PLEASE. THANK YOU LADIES AND ON
THE PHONE LINES IF YOU WISH TO-
A PUBLIC COMMENT AT THIS TIME
PLEASE PRESS ONE FOLLOWED BY
ZERO. AN A. T. T. OPERATOR WILL
GIVE YOUR LINE NUMBER QUICKLY
OFFLINE THE PLACE BACK IN THE
QUEUE. GET PER CALL A PUBLIC
COMMENT PLEASE PRESS ONE ZERO AT
THIS TIME AND WE WILL BEGIN TO
FIND FOURTEEN MISTER CHAIR
PLEASE GO AHEAD FOURTEEN. GOOD
MORNING MR CHAIRMAN MEMBERS OF
THE COMMITTEE CHRISTINE VALMONT
SPEAKING TODAY TO YOU ON BEHALF
OF THE CALIFORNIA PROFESSIONAL
FIREFIGHTERS. AND ALSO THE
WRITERS GUILD OF AMERICA WEST. A
VERY GRATEFUL TO THE
LEGISLATURE- FOR. EXPEDITING THE
DISCUSSION ON THIS POLICY
PROPOSED BY THE GOVERNOR AND WE
URGE YOUR SUPPORT TODAY ON. SB
ONE FOURTEEN. THANK YOU SO MUCH.
THANK YOU NEXT BIGGER. OPERATOR. ONE TWENTY TWO SAROS MUTED-
LINE TWENTY TWO YOU ARE OPEN
PLEASE GO AHEAD. THANK YOU VERY
MUCH ASSEMBLY ROSENBERGER WITH
SERVICE EMPLOYEES INTERNATIONAL
UNION I WANT EXCEL TO COMMENT TO
MY COLLEAGUES AND THAT'S BECAUSE
BEFORE- WE ARE INCREDIBLY
GRATEFUL FOR THE LANGUAGE IN SB
ONE FORTY COMPETE SICKLY
OFFICIALLY FOR THE- AND- THE
CARE TAKERS ARE WORKERS ARE NOT
ONLY. TRYING TO SHOW UP TO WORK
AND KEEP. THE COMPANY RUNNING
BUT ALSO MAKE SURE THAT THEY CAN
MANAGE THEIR HOME BUT THAT WAS-
INCREDIBLY HELPFUL FOR OUR
WORKFORCE- AND WE ALSO WANT TO
BE APPRECIATIVE OF THE DOLLARS
FOR THE ADMINISTRATIVE FEES FOR
THAT THE CHILD CARE SUBSIDY
IMPLEMENT OFTEN CAN. GO OUT
THANK YOU VERY MUCH. THE YOU
NEXT CALL. LIKE TWELVE YOUR OPEN
. HI KATIE HARTMAN A CALIFORNIA
TEACHERSASSOCIATION PTA
APPRECIATE THE LEGISLATURE AND
GOVERNOR COMMITMENT TO REINSTATE
COMMENT LEAVE AN EARLY ACTION
AND WE DON LIKE THE BAR AT THE
ONE FOURTEEN THANK YOU. THANK
YOU NEXT BIGGER. TWENTY THREE
PLEASE GO AHEAD. FEDERAL ON
BEHALF OF THE CALIFORNIA SCHOOL
EMPLOYEES ASSOCIATION IN SUPPORT
OF SB ONE ONE FOUR ASSEMBLY
MEMBER CAREER OR NEW COVERED MY
POINTS I JUST WANT TO REITERATE
THAT THIS BILL IS PART OF THE
STATE'S COMMITMENT TO PROVIDING
IN PERSON INSTRUCTION WILL
CONVENTICLE CLOSURES THANK YOU.
THANK YOU THE SPEAKER. HELLO
LINE CAN PLEASE GO AHEAD. GOOD
<c.magenta>ORNING GREEN OHIO CHILD CARE</c>
LAWCENTER WE APPRECIATE THE
ALLOCATIONS IN THE BUDGET TO
SUPPORT THE TEMPORARY RATE
INCREASES FOR CHILDCARE
PROVIDERS AB ONE FORTY SEVEN WE
ALSO URGE AT THE BEIJING CLEARED
FUNDING TO EXTEND THE WAIVER
FAMILY SPEAKING TO THE TENDER
THIRTIETH TWENTY TWENTY FOUR
WHICH IS PERMISSIBLE UNDER THE
AMERICAN RESCUE PLAN THE CDBG
SUPPLEMENTAL DISCRETION
DISCRETIONARY FUND AND CONTINUE
TO PAY PROVIDERS BASED ON THE
FAMILY UNIFIED NEED. RATHER THAN
ATTENDING PASSED JUNE THIRTIETH
TWENTY TWENTY Q. INTERNET DAY
PIECES TO ENSURE CHILD CARE
PROVIDERS THEY OPEN AND
CURRENTLY TO WORK. TO PROVIDE
FOR THEIR FAMILIES THANK YOU.
THANK YOU. LIKE TWENTY FIVE YOU
ARE UP PLEASE GO AHEAD. BETTER
HEARING NUMBERS OUR STORE AS A
STRATEGIES SIXTY ON BEHALF OF
THE NATIONAL INDEPENDENT VENUE
ASSOCIATION CALIFORNIA CHAPTER
WE ALSO LIKE TO ALIGN OUR
COMMENTS IN SUPPORT OF THE
SHUTTER VENUE OPERATOR AND
CONFORMING AS WELL AS THE
RESTAURANT REVITALIZATION PLAN
CONFORMITY. EVEN INTO THE WINTER
INTO THIS LAST DECEMBER JANUARY
ONLY CRIMES- CANCELED SHOWS-
THERE'S A LOT OF CONSUMER ACT
NOT CONCERN AROUND ATTENDING
LARGE GATHERED SO- THIS WILL GO
A LONG WAY IN HELPING KEEP-
INDEPENDENTLY OWNED MUSIC VENUES
MUSIC CLASS WILL RUN YOU. THANK
YOU SO MUCH. THANK YOU NEXT.
TWENTY SEVEN PLEASE GO AHEAD. HI
GOOD MORNING THIRTEEN AND
COMMITTEE MEMBERS KRISTOFF MEYER
CALLING ON BEHALF OF THE
AMERICAN FEDERATION OF STATE
COUNTY AND MUNICIPAL EMPLOYEES
CALLING IN STRONG SUPPORT OF AB
EIGHTY FOUR S. B. ONE FOURTEEN
BACKTRACKS PRESS OUR GRATITUDE
FOR LEADERSHIP FOR PRIORITIZING
ISSUE AND ENSURING THAT- PARENTS
WORKERS OF ALL KINDS CAN STAY
HOME WHEN THEY'RE SICK. THANK
YOU. THANK YOU THANK SPEAKER.
ONE THIRTY ONE PLEASE GO AHEAD.
SHARE GONZALEZ ON BEHALF OF
CALIFORNIA LIFE SCIENCES AND
SUPPORTERS BE THIRTEEN AND THE
TWO KILLERS THE PROVISIONS WHICH
ENDS ONE YEAR EARLY THE
TEMPORARY ONE THAT ON THE
ABILITY OF BUSINESSES TO USE NET
OPERATING LOSS DEDUCTION AND
RESEARCH AND DEVELOPMENT TAX
CREDIT. THANK YOU. THANK YOU
THAT'S BIGGER. THIRTY FIVE
PLEASE GO AHEAD. GOOD MORNING-
CHRISTENDOM BACK ON BEHALF OF
THE CALIFORNIA PARTNERSHIPS AND
DOMESTIC VIOLENCE CALLING IN
STRONG SUPPORT OF SB ONE
FOURTEEN THE COVETED NINETEEN
SUPPLEMENTAL PAID SICK LEAVE WE
REALLY APPRECIATE THE EARLY
ACTION AND URGE THE LEGISLATURE
AND GOVERNOR TO ENACT WITHOUT
DELAY. THANK YOU. THANK YOU NEXT
BIGGER. WHY TWENTY SIX PLEASE GO
AHEAD. MEMBERS OF THE COMMITTEE
KEVIN TO DRY THE ON BEHALF OF
NFIB- SPEAKING TODAY ON BEHALF
OF- S. B. ONE ONE FOR COVERT
SICKLY- WE WOULD ENCOURAGE THE
LEGISLATURE TO FIND ADDITIONAL
FUNDING TO PROVIDE A DIRECT
RELIEF TO BUSINESSES THAT
PROVIDE- COVERT SICKLY. THANK
YOU. THANK YOU NOT SPEAKER. LINE
TWENTY NINE YOU ARE OPEN. GOOD
MORNING CHEN MEMBERS SPENDING
ONLY WITH THE CALIFORNIA
TAXPAYERS ASSOCIATION MANY
COMPANIES MAKE SIGNIFICANT
INVESTMENTS IN CALIFORNIA
BECAUSE OF THE TAX INCENTIVES
THAT WERE LIMITED BY EIGHTY
EIGHTY FIVE AND TWENTY TWENTY
ESPECIALLY THE R&D TAX CREDIT
WHICH HAS BEEN A DRIVER OF
INNOVATION JOBS AND REVENUE FOR
THE STATE WE BELIEVE THE
RESTORATION OF THESE CREDITS AND
THAT OPERATE OFF ELECTIONS ARE
CENTRAL TO THE BEST OF
CALIFORNIA BUSINESSES. AND FOR
THAT REASON WE ARE PLEASED TO
SUPPORT. SB ONE THIRTEEN THANK
YOU. THANK YOU. ONE TWENTY ONE
PLEASE GO AHEAD. THANK YOU
MISTER CHAIR MEMBERS MATT
CARPENTER ON BEHALF OF THE
CALIFORNIA THAT A CONFERENCE OF
OPERATING ENGINEERS HERE IN
STRONG SUPPORT OF SB ONE ONE
FOUR- WE WOULD A LOT OF COMMENTS
THE LABOR THAT AN EXTREMELY
THANKFUL FOR ALL THE HARD WORK
THAT WENT. THANK YOU. THANK YOU.
THE SPEAKER. THIRTY FOR YOUR UP
PLEASE GO AHEAD. THANK YOU ABOUT
ONE HOUR HOMELESS WORKING
PARTNERSHIPS AND CANCEL DAY IN
STRONG SUPPORT OF SB ONE
FOURTEEN SUPPLEMENTAL PAID SICK
LEAVE CHARGING MANY OF THE
WORKERS WE WORK WITH.
SYMPATHETIC CRITICS HAVE BEEN
UNDER TO STAY HOME WORK THEY GET
UNABLE TO CARE FOR THEIR KIDS
HOME FROM SCHOOL AND AFRAID TO
GET A CLOSER SHOPPING THEY MIGHT
NOT FOR THANKS SO YOU VERY MUCH
. FOR YOUR ATTENTION THIS AND
AFTER THE KILLINGS A COUPLE.
THANK YOU. THANKS SEVENTEEN CALL. FOR THANK YOU FOR SHARING
COMMITTEE MEMBERS PRESS YOUNG
THE CHAMBER COMMERCE TODAY AND
SUPPORT OF SB ONE SPECIFICALLY
SUPPORT THREE AND OF THAT
OPERATING THE DOW TO LOOK THE
CAP ON BUSINESS CENTER PACK
CREDIT WHICH PUT THE CREW OF THE
MURDER RELIEF BY WHICH THE STATE
CAN FOR TO THE OF. REVILED FOR
AND SHOW MANY GRANTS IT WAS
FOURTEEN RELATE TO THE PASSED
THROUGH ENTITY TACK ATTACK
CREDIT PROGRAM THANK YOU VERY
MUCH. THANK YOU THE SPEAKER. WE
WILL LINE SIXTEEN PLEASE GO
AHEAD. GOOD MORNING MR CHAIRMAN
AND MEMBERS THIS IS MY QUEST ON
BEHALF OF THE STATE BUILDING AND
CONSTRUCTION TRADES COUNCIL WE
ARE IN STRONG SUPPORT OF SB ONE
ONE FOUR AND AB EIGHTY FOR THE
EXTENSION OF CO THAT SICKLY. THE
REALITY THAT CONSTRUCTION
WORKERS WOULD CONTINUE TO SHOW
UP TO WORK AS OPPOSED TO-
STAYING HOME WHILE THEY'RE SICK
IS NOT JUST THE DANGER TO THEIR
OWN CO WORKERS BUT ALSO TO THOSE
OF THE OTHER- CONSTRUCTION
WORKERS ON THE PROJECT TO THE
CLOSE PROXIMITY. ON THE JOB SITE
THANK YOU FOR YOUR TIME. THANK
YOU. ONE THIRTY THREE YOUR OPEN. THANK YOU WILSHIRE MEMBERS
QUALITY CARE TO BE AFTER THE
CALIFORNIA GROWERS ASSOCIATION
IN RESPECTFULLY OPPOSE OF AB AT
KORISTI WALK FOURTEEN THE- CODE
NINETEEN COUPLE MENTAL
BASICALLY- DJS NOT OPPOSED
PROVIDING LEGAL POINT THEY'RE
EXPOSED OR TECH POSITIVE BECAUSE
OF IT HOWEVER WE ARE CLOSE THE
LACK OF FUNDING TO PROPERLY
SUPPORT BUSINESSES WITH A COST
PER YEAR WHEN MATHIS THEY BUDGET
SURPLUSES AVAILABLE. YEAH REST
TIMELINE A LACK ABOUT REACH TO
DIFFERENT COMMUNITIES AND NOT TO
MENTION THE TOPIC THAT BECAUSE
OF THE PUMP ON THE COUCH- I
IMAGINE YOU HAVE GRACED. ANDERS
THANK YOU. THANK YOU BUT SPEAKER
. WE WILL LINE YOUR OPEN. THANK
YOU MR CHAIRMAN MEMBERS THIS IS
KATIE HANSON WITH THE CALIFORNIA
RESTAURANT ASSOCIATION
RESTAURANTS FOR THE FIRST TO BE
CLOSED DURING THE PANDEMIC IT
WILL BE THE LAST TO RECOVER FROM
THE DEVASTATING FINANCIAL IMPACT
OF THESE CLOSURES STILL TODAY%
RESTAURANTS ARE STRUGGLING WITH
A SHORTAGE OF WORKERS THAT IS
FORCING RESTAURANTS TO LIMIT
THEIR OPERATIONS. SPIKE IN COSTS
OF LABOR FOOD AND SUPPLIES AS
WELL AS ANY THAT THE BUSINESS
MAY HAVE INCURRED FROM THE
PANDEMIC SO ANY ADDITIONAL COST
INCREASES WILL IMPACT OUR
RESTAURANT ABILITY TO RECOVER
FOR THESE REASONS WE ARE OPPOSED
TO S. B. ONE FOURTEEN. THANK YOU
. THANK YOU NOT SPEAKER. WHY
NINE PLEASE GO AHEAD. THIS IS
KATIE WATER SMITH WITH THE
CALIFORNIA WORK AND FAMILY
COALITION WE'RE IN STRONG
SUPPORT OF SB ONE ONE FOUR COOK
AT NINETEEN SUPPLEMENTAL PAID
SICK LEAVE THAT'S POLICY WILL
SAVE LIVES AND WE URGE THE
LEGISLATURE AND GOVERNOR TO
ENACT IT AS SOON AS POSSIBLE
THANK YOU. THANK YOU. ONE TWENTY
EIGHT YOU ARE OPEN. GOOD MORNING
TURN MEMBERS SHALL DENTIST WAY
FOR YOU TO TAP YOU ASKED ME A
LOCAL THIRTY NINE THIRTY ON
BEHALF OF OVER A HUNDRED AND
FIFTY FIVE THOUSAND I JUST
HAPPENED A FAMILY CHILD CARE
PROVIDERS STATEWIDE WE WOULD
LIKE TO EXPRESS OUR STRONG
SUPPORT. IT ONE FOURTEEN ENDED
PENSION OFFICE DEPLOYMENT OF
BASICALLY AS WELL AS BE ONE
FIFTEEN AND AT THE FUNDING AT
THE PAID WITH TO THAT
DISTRIBUTION OFFICE SUPPLY
MENTAL DOLLARS YOUR FAMILY CHILD
CARE PROVIDERS. THANK YOU. THEY
YOU NEXT BIGGER. WHAT ELEVEN
PLEASE GO AHEAD. YES IT'S VERY
MEMBERS ALL RIGHT ONLY THINKING
ABOUT THE CALIFORNIA RETAILERS
ASSOCIATION WE'RE JOINING A
COALITION OF MORE THAN A DOZEN
BUSINESS GROUPS WITH ONGOING
CONCERNS ABOUT THE INSTITUTION
OF A THIRD TWO WEEKS
SUPPLEMENTAL PAID SICK LEAVE
MANDATE CLICK TO START THE
PANDEMIC- ONCE AGAIN THAT
MEASURE PROVIDES ANOTHER LAYER
MAY TAKE LEAVE ON TOP OF WHAT IS
ALREADY REQUIRED BY LAW MOST
NOTABLY THE COW OSHA ETS AND
REQUIREMENTS REPLIED EXCLUSION
PAY. AS WELL AS THE STATE'S
MANDATORY TYPICALLY LAW AS A
BILL COLLEGES MANY OF OUR
MEMBERS ALREADY PROVIDE SUB
MODEL PAID SICK LEAVE OF THEIR
OWN HOWEVER FOR SMALL AND MEDIUM
SIZED EMPLOYERS THERE ARE NO
LONGER FEDERAL TAX CREDITS
AVAILABLE TO COVER THE COSTS.
ALSO THAT RETAILERS AMONG US A
NUMBER OF INDUSTRIES THAT ARE
AMONG A NUMBER A NUMBER OF
INDUSTRIES THAT DO NOT BENEFIT
FROM THE R&D TAX CREDIT AND AN
OPERATING LOSS RESTORATION TO
THE SAME EXTENT AS OTHER
INDUSTRIES. BECAUSE OF MAJOR
COMES ON TOP THE NEIGHBORS CAN
DENTICULATED COSTS FOR EMPLOYERS
OVER THE PAST YEARS INCLUDE
INCLUDING PRIOR BASICALLY
POLICIES WORK WITH MY CLIENTS AB
TWENTY BILLION THAT INTO THE
UNEMPLOYMENT FUND WHICH WILL
RESULT IN SUBSTANTIAL
PRACTICALLY CAN COMING YEARS WE
THEREFORE AMANDA TO THE MEASURE
THANK YOU. THEY CAN EXPECT HER.
I'M THIRTY YOU ARE OPEN. GOOD
MORNING CHAIRMAN JOHNNY WITH THE
OKAY CITIES WITH A THAT YOU KNOW
AS THE WAR ON. WE SHOULD ALL THE
WORK IS DONE IS LANGUAGE IS. WE
HAVE CONCERNS WILL COME THE CAN
AND AT THE THIS MEASURE THE
CREATE GIVEN MINUTES BURDEN AND
CO TO PAY EMPLOYERS. WOULD LIKE
TO WITH THAT. TOO MANY TO ENSURE
CLARITY THINK THAT WITH PREVIOUS
AND- LEE REQUIRED. EITHER AND
THAT ARE IMPACT GOVERNMENT. WILL
NOT BENEFIT FROM THE CURRENT
PRICE TAG CREDITS WE LOOK. OVER
TO WORKING THROUGH ARKANSAS. I
LANGUAGE TO THE- THANK YOU.
THANK YOU THE SPEAKER. THIRTY
SEVEN PLEASE GO AHEAD. EACH
MORNING MISTER NUMBER RON LAPS
SPEAKING ON BEHALF OF THE SOCCER
AS- IN STRONG SUPPORT OF S. B.
ONE ONE FOUR THANK YOU. THANK
YOU THE SPEAKER. NINE THIRTY YOU
ARE UP. GOOD MORNING MR CHAIRMAN
MEMBERS CORRECT REYES THAT ON
BEHALF OF THE SILICON VALLEY
LEADERSHIP GROUP CORD SUPPORT OF
SB ONE THIRTEEN AND THANK YOU SO
MUCH FOR YOUR EXPEDITED WORK ON
THAT COULD GREATLY APPRECIATE IT
. THANK YOU NOT SPEAKER. FIVE
THIRTY EIGHT PLEASE GO AHEAD.
INGRESAR VIACOM CALIFORNIA- GOOD
MORNING MISTER CHAIR AND MEMBERS
ON BEHALF OF OUR FIFTEEN HUNDRED
LIFE SCIENCES MEMBER COMPANIES
AROUND STATE CALIFORNIA WE WANT
TO GIVE OUR BIG- STEAKS AND
APPLAUSE TO APPLY TO ALL OF YOU
FOR YEARS YOUR GREAT WORK ON SB
ONE THIRTEEN. CIVICALLY ARE
OWED- R. D. IN A WELL
RESTORATION ONE YOUR CURLY AND A
BIG THANK YOU TO YOURSELF AND-
THE COMMITTEE'S WORK THE
GOVERNOR SPEAKER OF THE PROTEST
THANKS SO MUCH FOR IT TO STOP
THANK YOU. THANK YOU. THE YOU
NEXT BIGGER. AT YUBA- AS
REMINDER CALL IT ONES VIEWS TO
MAKE UBLIC COMMENT. AND WILL
ALIGN. FORTY ONE. MY NAME IS
NINA WHILE HORRIBLE HORRIBLE UP
ON WITH R. P. CALIFORNIA AND WE
APPRECIATE THE OPPORTUNITY TO
SPEAK AT THE HEARING ON BEHALF
OF A. R. P. THREE POINT THREE
MILLION CALIFORNIA MEMERS. AND
ALL OLDER CALIFORNIANS. HE
STRONGLY. THE PROJECT EXPANSION
. OF COLDER NINETEEN SACRAMENTO
PAYCHECKS- BOTH AB. EIGHTY FOUR
OF ALL THE SUBJECT OF THAT
HEARING AT. ONE FOURTEEN WE DO
BELIEVE THAT. WORKERS INCLUDING
FAMILY CAREGIVERS MUST BE ABLE
TO TAKE THE TIME THEY NEED TO
CARE FOR THEMSELVES AND THEIR
LOVED ONES WHEN THEY BECOME ILL.
DURING PUBLIC HEALTH EMERGENCIES
SUCH AS THE COVER NINETEEN
PANDEMIC. I TIME BECAUSE CAL WE
TO MORE WE APPRECIATE ALL THE
WORK THAT HAS GONE INTO THIS
ISSUE- AND WE ARE. WE ARE
TEMPTED TO EXTEND THE
SUPPLEMENTAL SIX. LOT WITHOUT
DELAY. AGAIN WE THAT WORKERS IN
THAT INCLUDES FAMILY GIVERS MUST
ACCESS THING UP TO TEN TO PAY IT
ALL COME. BUT ESPECIALLY DURING
A CONFLICT TEN THANK YOU. THANK
YOU NEXT WEEK OR- THANKS FOR
YOUR GO TO LINE FORTY PLEASE GO
AHEAD. THANK MISTER CHAIRMAN TO
MEMBERS LUKASZ WITH THE IN
ASSOCIATION OF SHEET AIR AND
TRANSPORTATION WORKERS SMART
TRANSPORTATION DIVISION AND FULL
SUPPORT OF SB ONE ONE FOUR THANK
YOU. THE POWER I GOT. EXPECT
SPEAKER. THANK FORTY YOUR UP
PLEASE GO AHEAD. GOOD MORNING MR
MEMBERS OFTEN DENTAL ALL CALLING
ON BEHALF OF SHE'S EXTRA MEMBER
OF TO PROTECT US COALITION
WANTED TO JUST TALK ABOUT COME
ON THAT THE ONE FIFTEEN
GRADUATED WITH A CONTINUING
RESOURCES FOR THE IMPORTANT
ISSUES AND POINT OUT THAT- HAS
BEEN MOVED FORWARD INTO THE HOLE
BUDGET DISCUSSION THIS YEAR WILL
BE VERY IMPORTANT TO TALK ABOUT
SCHOOL TESTING. AND AFFORDABLE
COMPUTER SUBCOMMITTEE WHICH GIVE
US WHAT CENTER. ON THOSE ISSUES
THANK YOU AGAIN. THANK NEXT WEEK
OR- THANKS WE WILL GO TO. OUR
LINE FORTY YOUR OPEN OUR SKEWS
ME I THOUGHT WAS JUST WHO WE HAD
WILL GO TO FORTY THREE PLEASE GO
AHEAD. FORTY THREE YOU ARE OPEN. LAST TRIED FORTY THREE WOULD
YOU LIKE TO MAKE PUBLIC COMMENT. NOBODY IS RESPONDING OVER LINE
FORTY FIVE. GOOD MORNING LORD
GAVE NOT BE HAPPY CALIFORNIA
MANUFACTURING TECHNOLOGY SOCIAL
AS WELL THE AEROSPACE AND
DEFENSE LINE CALIFORNIA PRODUCT
SUPPORT- EIGHTY EIGHTY SEVEN AND
A ASSEMBLY THE RESTORATION OF
BEEN COMPETITIVE TAX CREDIT AND
THE- NET OPERATING LOSS
DEDUCTION APPROVED WE CAPPED
THANK YOU. AND THERE ARE NO
OTHER PARTICIPANTS QUEUED UP AT
THIS TIME MISTER CHAIR. THANK
YOU OPERATE IN THE- FOR PUBLIC
COMMENT IN THE COMMITTEE ROOM.
SEEING NONE AND SEEING NO
FURTHER COMMENTS FROM THE
COMMITTEE MEMBERS THEMSELVES- WE
WILL ENSURE THANK YOU.